hello welcome back to the GameSpot stage
here at e3 2016 I'm Lucy joining myself
and Scott on the couch today to talk
about let it die we have suda51
welcome from grass grasshopper
manufacturer and we have Tyler from
gung-ho Online Entertainment
what's the reception been like to let it
die let it die was revealed a couple
years ago it went quiet now you're back
showing it off its pursuing it meeny
miny do you dare to game what's good
today
mmm solitaire game on school tomorrow so
stay she ought to stay secure on the
unique ID the matter suno kutah
consciousness uno dos de there's a
killer on the Casillas so of course the
e3 2014 the game was announced and then
we kinda went quiet for about a couple
of years but during that time we were
working really really hard and we
finally put something out and made an
announcement at PAX East this year in
Boston but over that time period working
really really hard had a lot of ideas
and tried to get all these new ideas
implemented so the cycle was really just
work really hard to stay quiet work go
to work
drink saké go home sleep go to work
drink sleep and that kind of cycle
continued and continued and then we
finally had some great stuff that we
were able to bring to the world that pax
now at e3 so what is the overall premise
of let it die you know yeah Thomas so no
dough no luxury
so stay robust I know game oh my gosh
it's good and a little more multiplayer
pants Richard Acuna second volume animus
so the me is overall to explain what it
is it's kind of like a roguelike
hack-and-slash game but it's you start
off and only your underwear mmm you
throw into this game this world only in
underwear and you have to survive yeah
just like after moon let's get the
Moscow over don't worry are there are
female characters that are available but
they're also closed properly so there's
no concern there yeah nothing other than
a mother
totally millisecond Disney so the
players are thrown in and they don't
really know what's going on and but
they're in their Tower and they're gonna
just go and explore it to find out
what's really going on here including ah
you don't know navigate Oh Sigma's so
you're not just alone in this tower so
as you go through you really don't know
what's going on you can see it on our
shirts and on our pins and sometimes in
the game this this cool hip Grim Reaper
his name is uncle death he'll come in
he'll tell you what's going on if it
difficult to sort of reveal a new game
but wanting to keep that air of mystery
about it because even though you've told
me I kind of there is like so many more
things that I want to know about it but
I feel like knowing more about it would
ruin the experience yeah how'd you know
my you know my show got the moments kill
I thought she gave me the knowledge oh
ho that's new you know yeah honey what's
the mr. Leone oh gosh the Hawaii
Eureka not so they caught my story
convey to my Sudoku wow you know you got
in skiddo mushi thanks uncle mother
crying when you heard me the book or a
horrendous hit on the snare the
conductor nobody too chaotic in operated
either heretical
McCallum educator 2 News so dr. Koon GIK
dr. Scott day he don't you got on a
peewee big Artemis so of course there
are things that we would like to keep
hidden but of course if you want to know
more we have a little thing of things
that we could say right now so yes you
go to the tower you're going to be
raising your character making stronger
of course there's another meaning for
that as you go through that game cycle
because there's another game cycle that
involves some PvP action asynchronous
previous the first time we're doing
things with online capability so we
really want to bring meaning to what
you're doing when you figure out what's
going on the tower you're raising your
character and then using that to fight
against other people in a new way that I
guess you might not have seen before so
this is like when you when you when I
die in my game I could appear in someone
else's game
I don't even the character no game with
the team mascot yes yeah totally
happy right yeah so is my character
moving around is it based on the the
movements and actions I did in my game
or is it a new AI programming though
what does she go to the court or money
silica Sarika she got any stimulus money
Sheamus so to kind of follow what you do
best and kind of follow also it will
represent you because it'll have
equipment that you had that the player
hosted a motion lighting so if your
character goes out and beat someone else
you might get something really nice in
return it kinda reminds me a little bit
of the the pawns from Dragon's Dogma
yeah that sounds cool but actually I
haven't really played so sorry it's
interesting this it seems like I mean
given the way that that mechanic works
and given like the surreal and dark
looking tone of the game it feels like
this is this kind of obsession with
death I mean you even have uncle death I
was curious if you could talk about sort
of that theme and tell us a little more
about this world that we're seeing it
almost seems like kind of a like a
hellscape or something like you're
trying to escape from this like hellish
tower that's populated with the souls of
dead players I mean it's it feels very
dark and feels very death-obsessed those
themes pretty sharp
dun-dun-dun the stories are Coptic
they're movin on da da da da da cunha
what happiness so course you thrown the
towers really nothing you really don't
know what's going on but of course as
you play through the game and you get
you start unraveling the mysteries of
the hell you start realizing what your
existence is while you're there and
what's actually going on my songs you've
been like eating tonight so me must look
like one it's kind of a really
interesting world setting cuz you don't
know if you're actually alive or dead
maybe I don't know I made it a little
too much well just watching this and
seeing all these different characters I
mean there are all kinds of different
weapons there's duel with crazy melee
weapons like saw blades and barbed wire
but there also seem to be projectile
weapons I mean like right now we're
watching someone executed with the kind
of buzzsaw there is someone who gets cut
completely in half with a katana Evod
the action is very intense it's a very
violent game apparently must accumulate
each
yeah non-collision so there's really a
lot of weapons at level armor if you
guess you were to piece it them all
together and the variations you can have
it sorry it's a jack let's see it all
over so you gotta go finish the Natomas
so on top of that we each of these but
that's a Gore finish right each player
has a different kind of each weapon
actually has its own rage attack which
is like a special move and then each has
a special core finish so unique
finishing move for each weapon that you
have definitely you know reach the level
of Awesomeness and Mortal Kombat has
brought to the table but we really want
to try our best and see and hopefully
they think that we do something cool too
it reminds me a little of just when you
talk about like the story elements is it
gonna be some kind of like a main
mission or is it is it like Dark Souls
where you're just wandering around the
environment and you discover things and
pick up on story elements yourself and
it might slow you say it's kind of my
hint about economic Appetit you wanna
cut a scene in a parent's car today I'm
gonna check in on this with Omar how
about the character I detect a boss
fight oh sorry Doka so you gotta save
too much Valley but you said that this
is a kind of a really crazy world and
you've meet a lot of crazy characters as
you go through you'll meet a lot of
different characters and especially
there'll be some crazy boss fights you
can expect as well yeah actually one a
little more about the weapons system I
mean again what's kind of standing out
to me is all these different weapons
that you're seeing so will you collect
weapons as you go through the
environment can do craft weapons can you
customize weapons I was hoping you could
talk a little more about the weaponry
that we're singing I know it's good
kids'll tell you that it's pretty much
so there are some special ability so of
course you can pick up a lot of weapons
but we also have blueprints where you
can make some weapons as well yeah six
things of like dead rising or something
or you can build these really elaborate
weapons might see something quite
similar maybe
okay so it's PlayStation 4 exclusive but
I remember reading that you guys are
gonna have some kind of companion app is
that still plant it's peaceful no
exclusivity kita no come on you know how
much evil easy autumn on this kill oh
come on
Oh Buddha Moscow so you you remember
about the companion app we thought
they've ever forgot about it
uh no game no showing cardigans and
caught on de amalah not naughty much the
table so the game design has changed
quite dramatically over the past few
years so I guess you can say that
because of the design change that kind
of also went out with the change as well
yeah oh you really did your homework
thank you very much try you know one of
things I've always found really
fascinating about grasshopper
manufacturer games they always feel like
they're very much kind of a personal
vision like they're almost subversive in
a way that I was curious for Suda's take
on sort of his approach to game design
it seems like it's almost just devoted
to you know creating whatever is in his
mind and not so much worrying about you
know what's gonna appeal to a mass
audience or anything that I was curious
if that's sort of the mentality or if
maybe I'm just reading that into his
game you know
grasshopper game game design if I see
the Sangha it welcome to a Domo cut the
model reaction to ricotta gnudi matter
is even let's create a game with all
mantras let's grow to you you know not
very not the mascot okaaay doing this
weapon even assuming are demonic women
oh that oh god so crazy I'm not a talker
gibberish me I designed some quiet
Salamis
so of course we do really think about
what we think would appeal to others or
what people would enjoy or have fun with
when we do make the games but you can
definitely say that a lot of my hobbies
and what things that I like are things
that I've decided to put in the game on
a design from a design standpoint and
consistently seems like those types of
things are dark or brutal I was
wondering what attracts into these you
know just very bloody in in you know
high action kind of games and those
types of themes Sonoma Tonto semyonova
so no mark could I eat a my
you know I know my Chico oh you took my
action why didn't you call da doot doot
a token e re Mosca misogyny kazuto
conquer history but there are no boxing
karate team kobani
we are sensational source you can
understand with blood and bloodshed
especially for example and let it die
right now we put a demo out at PAX and
we also have a similar one at e3 right
now but in between that for the e3 build
he made sure that they increase the
bloodshed by 150% yeah beauty who do
that do you modern this little more much
in my book kill games at Chicago
kim chunsik I would create I know they
watch girls I mean it's not that what my
immediate goodness so in regards to that
the reason why it happens to be that why
we'll have a lot more blood is of course
it looks really cool but we really want
to take people away from reality and
make sure that they understand that the
game that they're playing this is a
completely separate reality this is not
reality so it's a whole different world
and people can go into this world and
enjoy it there does that make it
difficult the amount of bloodshed to
release in countries like Australia or
Germany where they have much stricter
rules on things like that that maybe we
do in the US or Japan or the UK yoshino
do need a religion either she's right
toga toga toga party mastodon desuno
concord are jobless so we have actually
had issues of that in previous titles
but i think this time will be okay do
you think that Australia and Germany
should be okay this is the first
combined effort between gung-ho online
entertainment and grasshopper
manufacture what's the working
relationship in like Tohatsu so no
relationship you need to know no country
discuss concerns on top no Maurice
tonight I'm a hotty mushy talk minutes
discussions the game design committee
Ted associates created the online
support assume Artemis it's a very it's
really awesome collaboration actually so
when all these grasshopper canopy we
also have a lot of input from gung-ho
online entertainment of course
especially from the sea
Kisuke Morishita and especially for
being strong in online aspects going
online and retainment didn't give us a
lot of input and a lot of really good
feedback on the online aspects of let it
die while making this game so we've been
working together really well actually
and it's been a lot of fun so one other
thing I think is really interesting
about Sudha's work and grasshopper
manufacturers very huge sequels in fact
almost no sequels I was curious why the
decision to just kind of create a new
game or a new franchise or a new
universe every time you set out to make
a game what's curious it's goody-goody
alteration was good do you know about -
can you do you re muscatel no Deema
that's kid water Marty Marty kaan cases
malvada mercy Ikaruga at the most
critical scrutiny no commercially normal
circular doctrine sweet item a snail
throw a lot of games I guess you could
say we'll put everything into it and try
to wrap everything up really nicely so
at the end really don't feel like we
should have to make a sequel and rather
make something new and get some new
ideas out there but in the case of No
More Heroes well there was a sequel and
we still maybe you'd like to make
another one so you guys announced let it
die a couple years ago you went quiet a
little bit of resurgence can you share a
release date with us before we go oh no
I don't know about this he'll don't ask
DCU alright thank you so much for
joining us guys for more III coverage
makes to make sure you stay tuned to
game spot calm